bienvenue dans cette émission spéciale
consacrée aux 40 ans de saint quentin en
yvelines on a déjà parlé ici de culture
architecture de santé on va aborder
aujourd'hui un autre thème celui des
transports comment se sont créés ces
réseaux de transport pour aller quand
même 150 mille habitants aujourd'hui qui
vive dans la communauté de 50 ha pour en
parler
michel logis bonjour bonjour vous êtes
le maire de montigny et vous êtes le
vice-président de la casse qui en charge
des transports
adressez-vous l'homme de la situation et
didier blanchet bonjour bonjour
donc vous êtes le directeur de ski bus
roulent très important évidemment
puisque c'était même la dette premier
transport vont en parler qui est arrivé
sur le sur le territoire et alors on va
répartir cette émission en trois parties
il y aura d'abord les premières années
ensuite ce qui s'est passé le
développement et puis aussi le futur
parce que il ya il va se passer beaucoup
de choses en matière de transport on
commence par les premières années
alors ni jalousie comment ça s'est passé
les premières années pour le transport
sur la sallaz sur la commune de saint
quentin
c'était une véritable histoire il faut
créer tout bref au tout créé puisque je
rappelle le cas de cette agglomération
cette ville nouvelle a été créée au
départ il y avait plus de communes qui
dressera en faisait partie
et puis surtout il y avait beaucoup de
villages donc la seule ville qui
existaient vraiment c'est et rap
cette étrave s'inquiétera péter trapp
avait déjà sa gare travail à sa guerre
puisque on la gare de triage de drap
existe déjà depuis longtemps et les
cheminots étaient fort nombreux déjà
dans le paysage saint quentinois dont
finalement si cette ville nouvelle s'est
créé là c'est parce qu'elle était le
long de la voie ferrée c'était déjà un
des atouts importants qui avait été
retenu c'est parce que nous étions
situés le long de la voie ferrée et que
nous permettait d'être à paris dont les
meilleurs délais ensuite eh bien qu
est-ce qu il ya eu il y avait déjà la
gare de la verrière méthane mais qui
n'était pas travailler mais oui apple
avait rien si on regarde un peu ce qui
s'est passé au début on est assez frappé
d'abord avec des bus ils partent tous de
la verrière et pas de trappe
parce que où tout déclenché parce que au
tout début le vet aménagement de saint
quentin s'est fait sur sa partie ouest
on a commencé parce qu'autour y avait
les villes de elancourt d'aussi de
maurepas et de coignières il faisait
partie alors exactement qu'il faisait
déjà partie du périmètre à l'époque dont
c'est comme ça que les jo se sont
organisés donc avec finalement trois
gars une gare historique attrape une
guerre qui a été reconstruite qui à la
gare de la verrière et puis surtout les
gars qui n'existait absolument pas et
qui était aménagé en paix monsieur
deschamps c'est la gare et de montigny
en 75
voilà il ya des images d'entre les gens
qui habitaient là se souvienne c'est à
dire que c'était au milieu de rien
presque sept gardes
il fallait fallait mettre des bottes
pour y aller c'est au milieu de rien et
puis surtout c'était une guerre qui a
été dimensionné on sait pas trop comment
puisqu'on ne savais pas le nombre de
personnes qui allaient venir on ne
savait pas le nombre d'entreprises qui
allait s'installer
c'est un vrai pari c'est un vrai pari
donc a été consultée au milieu de nulle
part et finalement d'un petit à petit
elle a aggloméré autour d'elle
toutes les constructions que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui on a commencé par
l'immeuble internationale tant de
l'activité et puis autour mais alors de
l'autre côté des voies ferrées faut se
rappeler que au tout début nous avions
un hypermarché qui s'appelait heureux
marché à l'époque qui était de l'autre
côté des voies ferrées c'est dire que
quand les habitants de montigny de nuire
au cours deux voisins devaient faire
leurs courses ils devaient franchir la
voie ferrée pour aller de l'autre côté
dont tout au nord tout en aval c'est là
donc que la vie a commencé
et là en plus nous étions pas tout à
fait sûr montini puisque il y avait une
autre commune qui faisait partie de
notre agglomération qui s'appelle bois
d'arcy et qui venait jusqu'à ce niveau
là exactement donc après il ya eu des
redécoupages au niveau des limites
communales
tout ça c'est en voie d indifféremment
20 le transport a commencé comme ça et
donc les les politiques qui se sont
installés aux commandes à ce moment là
au milieu des années 70 eh bien on
commençait à créer quelques l'idée de
transport de bus et c'était pas en vin
et eau sur l'ouest côté c'est à côté en
arrière je veux le dire il va en gros
cinq lignes ferrées de la gare de la
verrière et l'encours de la gare de la
verrière à elancourt nouveaux horizons
d'un garde la verrière bois de maurepas
garde la verrière maurepas village et
gare de la verrière il encore tout à
fait oui parce que si c'est là que les
premières constructions les premiers
aménagements ont été réalisés sur 50 ans
des films ou une précision de la ce sur
ce que vous disiez parce que c'est assez
enfin étonnant au fond on construit une
gare mais où c'est très bien si veuillez
voir combien les voyageurs si à l'époque
on sait pas très bien s'il va y avoir
beaucoup d'entreprises ou pas enfin on
est un peu dans le temps dans le vague
tout à fait parce que j'avais
je crois qu'il ya eu des pionniers il y
à des paris qui ont été faits je connais
d'autres villes nouvelles en france qui
n'ont pas eu le même succès donc vous
voyez bien qu'elle y eut aussi quelques
airs est avec nous on a cette chance là
d'avoir contribué à la réussite de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et c'est vrai
que le transport est un des atouts ya
même fort sur saint quentin en yvelines
mais comme je vous le rappelle sept gars
là est d'une part elle n'était pas assez
dimensionné et puis surtout elle n'avait
pas un côté très fonctionnel on le voit
aujourd'hui et on voit et puis on y
reviendra un petit peu plus tard parce
que on a quand même un bel avenir pour
pour dissiper ce qui pourrait être aux
malentendus encore puisqu'il y avait
cette gare de trappes qui existaient et
qu'on voit qu'il est laid les lignes de
bus viennent plutôt de l'as verriers
alors vous dites c'est le développement
de l'ouest
il n'y a pas de n'y a pas d'enjeu
politique je veux dire c'est pas parce
que tu rappes est une ville communiste
s'était pas ko nous diront je pose la
question parce que je suis autant plus
que c'était pas que là le scad c'est à
dire la structure intercommunale de
l'époque était dirigé par un président
communiste mais vous voyez il ya aucune
là aucune de ces problèmes politiques
aucune ambiguïté tout simplement c'est
dû à la proximité
je crois que ça servait à rien de faire
partir des personnes de l'ail de la gare
de trappes les faire voyager 2 à travers
les rues de drap pour aller à l'autre
bout tout tout de a l'ouest dont je
crois que c'était la solution simple la
solution de facilité
c'était la proximité et la rapidité si
on veut on va encore parler mais si on
veut que les transports soit efficace
encore faut-il qu'ils soient rapides
absolument dit des blancs c'est
justement le but ce qu'on appellera plus
tard ce qui lui sauva ça prend une
ampleur et une importance
très forte dès le début oui en fait
lorsque la planification a été instauré
à partir des années comme vous disiez
monsieur logis à partir des années 70
les élus se sont tournés vers le
syndicat des transports parisiens ce
après les steppers à l'époque et à la
demande de la communauté d'agglomération
qui s'appelait le scan comme vous dites
monsieur loger il a été décidé de créer
un réseau de transport alors à partir
des cinq lignes que vous avez cités en
75 et depuis nous avons été reconduit en
termes de partenariat puis le réseau
s'est appelée ski bus dans les années 80
voyez donc il ya eu voilà sept ans
appuyé la guerre des entreprises
existantes comme les cars périer alors
ce sont des commandes et des
transporteurs qui sont affrétés mais le
réseau lui-même s'appelait 35 ans tard
il était géré par la ratp puisqu'à
l'époque les élus de la communauté
d'agglomération ont souhaité confier
l'exploitation à un groupe public donc
le groupe ratp sous l'égide du jus du
stp ski bus est passé
c'est une filiale de la ratp qui
s'appelait enfin le réseau s'appelait 35
entamée c'est une filiale de la ratp
avant que soit créé le groupe ratp
développement c'était une fidèle de les
rater parce que les élus souhaitait
confier à un groupe public
la planification des transports en même
temps ce que se construisaient les
villes voilà et donc le réseau de bus il
a il a l'intérêt droit de transporter
les gens qui habitent
dans la communauté jusqu'à leur lieu de
travail c'était essentiellement ça alors
il y avait un double je dirais une
double intérêt un double intérêt c'était
de transporter les gens sur paris
puisqu'il y avait quand même la gare que
c'était monsieur g et puis commencer à
réaliser des dessertes inter-cités 1
avec des lignes et c'est pour cela que
on est passé de 5 lignes à plus d'une
vingtaine de lignes assez rapidement au
fur et à mesure de l'extension de la
cité va plus comme ça des différentes
communes
mais ce qu'il veut c'est appeler le nom
de ski bus et 1992 92 16 et avant
c'était donc c'est ce que 30 50 ans 50
ha alors justement dans les années alors
nous avons un petit peu mais dans les
années 2000 on va construire des voies
propres à ces bus c'est ce qu'on appelle
le bus en site propre je vous propose de
regarder ce sujet c'est sans doute le
chantier de l'année en ville nouvelle le
transport en commun en site propre
devrait être ouvert aux bus au cours du
quatrième trimestre cette semaine une
nouvelle tranche concernant la
sécurisation des feux sur le boulevard
leclerc de montigny a commencé le tcsp
sur un confort supplémentaire pour les
usagers du bus il y aura une nette
amélioration et du temps de trajet et de
leur confort aussi c'est à dire que là
on est sur des voies très confortable
pour les autobus qui en plus une
géométrie qui pourra s'adapter sans
aucun problème si on devait changer de
mode
dans le futur à terme le trajet entre la
gare routière de saint quentin également
en train d'être refaite et la mérantaise
amani passera de 18 à 10 minutes
le trafic des bus sera fluidifier par un
système de régulation des feux qui leur
donnera la priorité aux croisements
c'est pas une hégémonie de l'autobus
quand on parle de priorité simplement
l'autobus lorsqu'ils approchent un
carrefour
déclenche ou accélère le cycle de feu et
après tout tout rentre dans l'ordre
qu'il ne stoppe pas les voitures il
accélère simplement un cycle ce tronçon
saint quentinois n'est que le premier
maillon d'une chaîne qui devrait à terme
relier massy dans l'essonne
voilà donc ce bus en site propre
écoutez moi j'ai vécu ça j'ai vécu ça
puisque j'habite montigny j'habite
monter depuis 1985 d'accord voilà après
j'ai aussi eu quelques fonctions auprès
de mon prédécesseur ni malade ou et puis
je suis devenu premier adjoint de cette
ville leur vendre être le maire depuis
2004 et donc j'ai bien connu cette
époque là j'étais arrivé et bien tout
simplement parce que j'étais journaliste
sur versailles et je cherchais un
endroit pour acheter ma maison et
justement je fais partie de ces
pionniers de la ville nouvelle où on
pouvait trouver sur 55 des habitations à
des prix tout à fait compétitif donc
voilà donc c'est pour ça que je suis
venu à bondy le boursier comme beaucoup
de personnes qui d'ailleurs était à peu
près de ma dommages et des ratios grave
bon c'est comme ça que je suis rêveur
montigné qu'ensuite j'ai été emporté
dans le tourbillon de la vie politique
mais avec beaucoup de plaisir et je dis
en plus avec aucun regret en tout cas de
cacher ce fait c'est vrai que j'ai donc
vous avez vécu j'ai vécu soit se
déplacer et ça n'a pas été simple parce
que c'était quelque chose de tout de
tout à fait nouveau c'était inédit
c'était inédit donc on a créé cette
première ligne d'un site propre
il a fallu que on arrive à convaincre
les habitants ce qui m'a aussi simple
que ça parce que faire passer comme ça
des voix certains habitants pensaient
que ont créé une véritable autoroute au
milieu de notre rap de notre site et
donc ça n'a pas été évident et puis ce
qui a surtout c'est que autant nous nous
étions innovant précurseur mais ce qu'il
a manqué ensuite c'était de pouvoir
poursuivre parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
bien de la banque raymond n'a créé que
dans la partie s ii
saint-quentin entre gelé dire la gare de
montigny et je veux dire la sortie de
notre agglomération côté c'est à dire
aux voisins manigand vous voilà alors on
va parler dans un instant on va finir
les vacances à quatre grands partis de
la démission à ce qui va se passer dans
l'est dans le futur puisque c'est au
fond ça qui intéresse les
téléspectateurs mais je propose qu'on
revienne quand même la deuxième partie
du haut on appelle du rêve à la réalité
c'est à dire ce qui s'est passé bah de
des débuts jusqu'à 11 jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
alors voilà ce qui ce qui s'est passé en
fin depuis le début qu'on avait vu tout
à l'heure jusqu'à jusqu'à la période
actuelle
ça a été quand même très fort
développement add transports oui
effectivement nous avons développé le
réseau de transport en commun avec la
communauté d'agglomération qui
maintenant une délégation du syndicat
des transports d'île de france donc je
dirais la main la main de développer de
la main la main en tout cas pour
développer son réseau tout en rendant
compte au stif puisque le stif
l'autorité organisatrice des transports
je rappelle quand même que le cette
autorité fixe la rémunération et le prix
des billets il faut que nos
téléspectateurs et sage c'est parce
qu'il use c'est le stif qui fixe pour
l'île de france
il s'est donc les syndicats les
régionales a et donc avec la communauté
d'agglomération nous développons le
réseau pratiquement tous les ans il ya
des améliorations aussi bien pour les
plans de déplacement inter entreprises
que pour les lignes scolaires etc
donc on en parlera peut-être en détail
et tout à l'heure les aspire tout en
mouvement le financement des transports
fait par qui elle a alors le financement
ce qu'il faut savoir
30%
du prix du ticket c'est le voyageur
c'est donc le client qui le paysage est
dans l'usagé enfin j'aime bien le jeu
peut faire le mot client d'ailleurs
c'est plus raison que voilà et 70% par
contre ce financement émane des
collectivités territoriales du stif qui
collectent des retraites notamment
auprès des entreprises avec le versement
transport dans 7 70% externe et 30% par
le client mais jalousie c'est un des
gros modèles de la communauté c'est pas
le plus gros budget mais ça fait partie
et même des investissements importants
réalisés par notre communauté d'agglo
faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui nous avons on
a parlé de l'historique
aujourd'hui nous avons réseau de
transport ont des plus importants de la
région ile-de-france eux puisque c'est
le plus important
après le réseau ratp de bari oui ok mais
vu que ambulance à jeu bien donc ça veut
dire que aujourd'hui à leur bal on va
parler chiffres avec précision
aujourd'hui c'est un réseau qui coûte 35
millions d'euros d'accords par an et qui
finançait dont qui financent et donc par
le site comme disait monsieur blanchet
mais la côté d agglo donne toutes les
années quatre millions 4 millions alors
que nous bahn ne sommes pas maîtres du
réseau sommes pas propriétaire d'un des
lignes aujourd'hui son propre et air de
rien simplement ben on participe quand
même à l'effort pour le service public
rendu donc à nous habitants et pas
simplement nos habitants parce qu'il ya
aussi toutes les personnes travaillent
dans nos entreprises donc c'est très
très important aussi qu'on puisse
assumer ce service mais aujourd'hui
monsieur blanche on parle et on est
arrivé quand même un réseau très très
important en dehors de ski bus sur dix
faut savoir qui à peu près 44 ligne qui
passe sur 51 divine entre les lignes ce
qui est bus puisse plus les lignes
interurbaines qui nous permettent de
partir aussi vers le nord et le sud
département ou vers paris
donc c'est aujourd'hui c'est à peu près
160 bus 160 bus qui sillonnent en
permanence et 6 mai ce chiffres sont
bons on doit parcourir 5,8 millions de
kilomètres par an
c'est qu'ils sont parcourus par les 160
bus qui font partie de votre adresse au
ski bus voilà est important alors il ya
aussi eu un chantier on va regarder un
switch est là dessus sur la rénovation
de la gare de montille on dit maintenant
la gare de montigny 50 ans à écoutez moi
je pense que on appelle ça depuis
longtemps la gare de saint-quentin sauf
que vous de me dire la gare de
saint-quentin menti parce qu'il faudrait
dire aux cinquante ans après la gare de
saint-quentin trappe et la gare de
saint-quentin là si on veut être leader
technologique
alors on va voir sur le le chantier de
rénovation de la gare de 50 à remonter
ni et puis après on va parler évidemment
de l'avenir qui est très important
rappelez vous c'était au mois de janvier
les commerces de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines étaient déplacés à
l'extérieur
peu de temps après palissades et
barrières fleurissaient dans la salle
des pas perdus
objectif des travaux une reconfiguration
pour valoriser un espace qui accueille
quotidiennement 70 mille voyageurs deux
fois plus que dans les années 70 à
l'époque de sa création la semaine
dernière réunion publique à montigny
l'occasion pour les habitants de
découvrir que le projet s'étend aux
abords de la gare pour varault de enppi
peu de fraîcheur et surtout une facilité
dans l'utilisation puisque ce sera un
pôle multimodal important avec bien sûr
les transports en commun donc les trains
et les rer mais aussi les taxis les bus
bien sûr et aussi les véhicules
électriques qui seront nouveau sans
oublier aussi une vélostation donc pour
tous ceux qui font ce dvd placer deux
roues parmi les espaces à rénover le
carré gare avec la diagonale et les
places choiseul le tollé charles de
gaulle en état de dégradation avancé en
charge de cette partie du projet jean
christophe nani architectes paysagistes
et urbanistes
depuis un an il emprunte six fois par
semaine la gare de saint-quentin
son idée créer une équerre d' espaces
publics dans le prolongement du parc du
centre une manière de rendre la guerre
plus visible et plus accueillante
particularité l'introduction de verdure
un véritable challenge selon l'urbaniste
on est sur un espace très contrainte
technique
sur dalle c'est à dire qu'on a des
parkings souterrains en dessous et puis
à des contraintes techniques et une gare
routière aussi du coup la pouëze un peu
de ce projet c'est malgré ce sous-sol
complexe de pouvoir planter et compris
des arbres et des espaces verts en tout
cas aux surfaces autre changement la
transformation de certains espaces
jusque-là dédiée au stationnement
la requalification de la rd 10 avec un
regroupement des lignes de bus en gare
routière et le réaménagement de l'avenue
du pas du lac afin d'assurer une liaison
plus sécurisante pour les piétons les
vélos et les véhicules entre la place de
la paix céleste c'est à dire
l'emplacement du futur vélodrome et la
place pompidou
côté chiffres la mairie annonce 23
millions d'euros dont des subventions du
stif de la région ile-de-france et du
conseil général
les travaux devraient commencer au
deuxième semestre 2012
auparavant les habitants seront invités
à donner leur avis lors d'une enquête
publique début janvier
si tout va bien la réhabilitation
devrait être achevée en 2015
petite pépite pour les amoureux de la
nature sachez que la mairie est
actuellement en négociations avec
renault pour tester des véhicules
électriques aux abords de la gare sur le
modèle autolib
alors nous abordons maintenant la partie
de l'avenir évidemment alors là déjà un
mou quand même sur la gare multimodale
qu'est ce que ça signifie ça signifie
que sur un même site on va pouvoir
trouver tous les moyens de transport
une gare des gens on pense au train non
bien sûr il ya des trains cars et trains
deuxièmement il ya aussi les la gare
routière j'irai demain même les gares
routières puisque nous allons créer une
nouvelle
sur la partie nord de des voix donc ce
sont aussi les bus se sont aussi bien
les personnes qui viennent de prendre
leur transport en commun rapide donc car
ils veulent a donc tout ça il faut que
tu es un calme et l'eau il ya aussi les
vélos
il y a les taxis et il se lance aussi
dans des mises à disposition de
véhicules électriques dont tout ceci
crée un pôle multimodal très très
important et je pense que avec cette
nouvelle organisation sera sûrement la
gare la plus fréquentée du département
des yvelines bien avant la guerre des
chantiers alors on va évidemment
apporter les chantiers qui sont en
rapport avec ce qu'on appelle le grand
paris mais peut-être avant au fond
qu'est ce qui marche bien dans les
transports aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui
manque
alors déjà ce qui marche bien c'est
j'allais dire super je suis peut-être un
petit peu chauvin mais si ce qui y est
dit non je parle de 115 ans
c'est tout ce qui est maîtrisée par la
communauté de l'agglo à tout ce qu'on
maîtrise je pense qu'au delà des
évolutions
je rencontre monsieur blanchet et on
travaille sur des aberrations de ligne
vire de tout temps tous les mois on
essaie de pouvoir apporter des
modifications
on travaille par exemple avec les
entreprises sur des plans de déplacement
interentreprises pour essayer de d'aussi
fort c est la preuve et d'être plus près
surtout pour bois adapter les bus aux
horaires les personnes doivent l'épreuve
est par contre vallée vous avez vu le
transport en site propre on a fait les
aménagements on a aussi des projets
entre la gare de trappes et la gare de
la verrière entre la gare de montigny
est la clef de saint-pierre donc nous on
travaille en a des projets on est prêt à
mettre des moyens
simplement parce que je constate
constate c'est que tout le monde parle
des transports en commun mais en 15 ans
va mettre dix minutes de plus pour
l'appareil ça c'est l'adversaire c'est
la réalité parce que la sncf change ses
horaires de manière régulière et
finalement chaque fois on perd on perd
parce que il ya eu aucun la forme
récente de changement d'horaire mais
nous nous ça nous aurait perdu ait
encore perdu sur la fin de l'année
dernière on n'a pas dû cinq minutes qui
se cumulent j'avais eu des retards il
n'y a jamais eu aucune amélioration dont
moi ce que je constate c'est que en 15
ans
on va mettre dix minutes de l'essence
pour aller à paris pour aller à paris
alors qu'on nous demande d'aller plutôt
vers les transports en commun donc là
dedans il n'y a pas de logique et chaque
fois qu'ils changent leurs horaires il
faut que nous travaillons avec eux pour
pour qu'on puisse adapter donc tout ça
ça représente un budget considérable de
perte de temps énorme et là dessus c'est
vrai que au départ n'est pas les oignons
n'est pas les plus grands gagnants et je
rappellerai aussi du matériel et qui
bien d'autres dispositions on encore les
petits gris qu'on appelle vous savez ces
trains où il fait très froid l'hiver est
rude qualité alors que normalement si on
voulait attirer de nouveaux usagers des
transports en commun il faudrait aussi
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient choyés qui
soit qu'elle fait me dans un matériel
adapté aux besoins actuels
donc moi ce que je vois c'est ça se sait
surtout ça il a fallu que l'on maîtrise
heures au sucre ont maîtrisé c'est très
bien de même que regarder on attend avec
impatience depuis de très nombreuses
années le projet ouvrir largement de la
ligne c'est vrai qu'ils pourraient le
moins jusqu'à la verrière à coignières
voir rambouillet ce qui ferait aussi une
gare de monthey ni un peu moins
fréquentées avec moins de voix pour
aller au bout de sa prière alors même si
les avons chez nous si nous avons des
parkings important mais je veux dire il
ya une circulation qu'on pourrait un peu
partagé avec d'autres
voilà vous savez on est prêt à partager
à 50 m beaucoup de choses max qui va et
ce qui ne va pas non plus c'est sûr sûr
sûr l'avenir par exemple
l'avenir nous
c'est l'avenir on le conçoit avec la
communauté d'agglomération pour
travailler comme disait monsieur logis
encore davantage avec les entreprises
sur les plans de déplacement
inter-entreprises ski bus fait partie de
l'association delta ce qui avec les
grandes entreprises du secteur mais
aussi avec les pme parce qu'on n'oublie
pas les pme et donc le but c'est quand
même d'améliorer encore et encore les
transports en commun sur le territoire
oui dans les petits exemples qu'on peut
citer aussi il ya une aberration totale
vous avez vous avez aujourd'hui les ter
les trains qui arrivent de la région
centre de chartres le mans qui ne
s'arrête pas menti ni donc alors que des
personnes de travail et elles sont
nombreuses à travailler
je rappelle est le nôtre pas loin notre
pôle économique c 105 millièmes
donc aujourd'hui il ya des personnes qui
travaillent à montigny qui parce qu'ils
passent à montigny tous les tous les
matins mais qui s'arrête à versailles
qu'il change de train pour revenir
alors on a quand même un mot parce qu'il
ya aussi de grands shows tenu le sentier
du grand paris qui va probablement aussi
la dimension des transports dans cette
région et notamment à saint quentin
qu'est ce qu'on peut en attendre très
précisément des coûts teneur nous
donnerait beaucoup on a été un peu déçu
moment où le projet a été publié et puis
finalement on est l'univers tu parles je
demande mais ça c'est arrivé après il
faisait pas partie du grand louis est
elle comme on dit donc comme n'a été
oublié par le grand huit
on ne sait quand même débrouillé pour
faire pression et avoir quelque chose
donc on va voir ce métro léger orly
massy plateau de saclay saga versailles
jusqu'à versailles chantiers mais en
passant par saint quentin normalement
doit voir deux gars sur sur saint
quentin
moi je croise les doigts savez quand je
suis un peu comme saint thomas je ne
crois que ce que je vois et j'attends
beaucoup
en tous les cas c'est vrai que c'est
quelque chose qui est attendu avec une
patience très très grande de la part de
nos habitants et aussi de la part de
nous
de nos entreprises bien sûr qu' aucun
regret à leurs besoins alors c'est vrai
que là le métro léger normalement
devrait se faire plus rapidement peut
être que les autres alors est ce qu'on
sera servi avant je l'espère mais moi
j'attends de voir
en tout cas ce que je vois aussi qui
progresse c'est finalement la continuité
du transport en site propre que l'on
avait initié sur et qui normalement
devrait sur le plateau de saclay et
réunir le département des yvelines et de
l'essonne
merci infiniment voilà il ya encore
beaucoup de gros chantiers sur les
transports merci infiniment michèle
losier merci beaucoup merci longer merci
et à très vite pour un nouveau rendez
vous sur les 40 ans de saint quentin en
yvelines